oh this is so cool this is awesome
okay wait this is really really cool
this is this is a picture of philidor
so that was basically the guy that was
known at the time look at when this book
was published
chess the chess game uh
brought into systematic order
uh by alexander petrov
parts one and two theory of chess
st petersburg uh typed
typed up by 1824.
okay this is old russian so in the 1800s
there is a bunch of russian characters
in the alphabet that are not used today
it's hard for me to read this uh
to the lovers of chess
that was the publisher but
russian was a lot more modern in the
eight in the early 1800s than english
was like
you could you could get the sense that
there were people like us because like
the language
was a lot more similar but the alphabet
is different so it's hard to read
um the name
chess is derived from
the iranian word shah or
the arabic word sheikh which means tsar
or king
the chess game
in the grand sense
yeah you can basically saying chess is
awesome and the next
in the next paragraph is saying chess is
awesome
chess is ancient blah blah but we want
the moves we want to see how he notates
yes no that's not a diagram that's weird
oh he calls the bishop differently so
the bishop used to be called a fitzer in
russian
so development of the bishop
uh forced to win gambit gambero
that's uh sacrifice
close
interval
knights rook yeah so he just defines
everything
well but there's no actual like chess
moves here
i think it's just maxim oh it's just
like rolls
okay develop the like king side night
before the king side bishop and stuff
and that these are like uh okay general
rule
all of the strength of the game uh
can is contained in the fact it's
contained in the connection of two pawns
in the center of the board so e4 and d4
in order to conquer the control of like
a flank
yeah there's no actual moves though oh
there is
what is this
wow this is so interesting so notation
wasn't like a thing
game one okay this is awesome
this is game one white black
ha king spawn four squares
k it says kings pawn king four squares
pawn king four squares kings knight
three squares queens knight three
squares
white's bishop king for
wow so it's basically old notation
zoom it in
okay this is what it says basically
it's not all it's not it's not algebraic
i guess not
so annotation didn't even exist so it
says
pawn king for squares
king four squares and then castle is
is just castle
um so this is an italian
white's queen no this is queen's bishop
three
so basically this is this is like uh
algebra
or what is the old what is the bad
notation descriptive
and then knight takes pawn b-e-r
is like takes the abbreviation for takes
this is cyrillic i should play this out
on a board okay
let's play this out on a board fine
let's look at the game he gives an
18 20.
yeah the russians are interested e4 e5
pawn king four squares pawn king four
squares
kings knight three squares kings knight
queens knight three squares
white's bishop four squares
i mean you guys can read what i'm
reading white blacks
if it is okay white's black's bishop to
the queen side
pawn queens bishop three
knight pawn four
kings pawn takes pawn takes check
oh this is this is this line it's a
famous line
uh check coin okay knight
c3 oh this is probably the graco game
castles knight takes
knight takes takes and now the move is
queen b3
the modern move is queen b3
okay king so where were we pawn takes
spawn
and a check the castle
takes takes bishop takes
queen v3
okay queen b3 bishop takes in look c
footnote three we will check footnote 3
after the game
this is a very famous game that's been
known since the 16th since the 1600s
check
king moves aside bishop four squares
um bishop four squares
four yeah queen bishop g5 this is
correct
knight two squares
okay
yup king to kings knight to king spawn
takes d4
bishop h5
d5 queen h
queen f3 check bishop f5
take the knight this is probably not the
best for white i think
uh bishop takes knight king takes
one sec yeah
mate is coming in two moves don't worry
one second i'm just checking
so check there
so it says bishop takes oh oh the king
takes the bishop jesus
okay i'm trying to read this
so where were we queen f3 check bishop
f5
oh bishop takes bishop
sorry um
this is all correct
one section oh three
hmm so this is something like this
oh bishop g6 ah bishop g6
airship g6 i think d5 queen f3 check
bishop f5 bishop takes f5 there we go
that's that's it
and then pontix takes
so i think it's like this there's some
move
and the mate is like this okay um
the other bishop should be on f4 but
yeah something something to this effect
this is basically right
uh and then in the footnotes
yeah so basically basically he's giving
all these games
uh game number two oh the footnotes are
are themselves other games like their
variations and stuff
okay so
that basically is one of the earliest
books ever written
now there was an even earlier book
written on chess
um let me just go to the speedrun scene
okay so basically the earliest book ever
written
on chess also happens to be one of the
earliest books ever written in the
english language
because earlier books had been written
in the uh latin language
there was a guy named william caxton
william caxton
was uh a let me go full cam for this
i'm going william caxton was an
englishman
he was like a businessman he was a
printer he printed books
uh born 14 14 22 died 1491.
he was like a diplomat he was like one
of those you know he use a cool dude
and he wrote one of the earliest books
ever written in the english language
that also happened to be called the game
and play of the chess
the game and the play of the chess this
was written in the 1400s
let's see if we can find it um
in this original edition online
the game but i don't think it contains
actual chess moves it just contains
chess as an analogy to life
yes gutenberg.org it exists
i guess i i bet you people didn't know
this
yeah so there's
there okay it's written in the kind of
old text
that um that is unreadable for us
but it's been translated
um let me see
let me do a search for chess
a very little practical bearing on the
game
so it's called that but it's not
actually
[Music]
really about chess
i'm just doing a search of chess in the
book
okay let's let me show it it's kind of
cool no it's not it's not been
translated the text it's
no no that hasn't been trust me look at
what i'm reading
look at look at what i'm trying to read
this
uh it's been translated into like modern
text
not chess
i'm just doing the second chapter of the
first treaty
shows who found the first play of the
chess yeah great this is very
understandable
chess men blah blah blah duchess duchess
i don't want dutch riches riches see
the word chess is actually not really
contained very often
for as much as the noble person cannot
yeah i don't this is this is old english
this is actually old english
the fourth treaty and the last of the
progression of the force of play of the
chess
tractatus treaties is treaties
used about the things that pertain
pertain
to the forms of the chessmen and of
their offices
this is a photo of someone playing chess
in the 14 frickin hundreds
that's kind of cool um
i mean this is really cool uh but the
last thing we're gonna find
look at this uh look at this dude just
like casually playing chess
uh look at this dude just like casually
playing chess
yeah i don't know about this position i
feel like you wouldn't want to mess with
someone like that
um but the reality is we wouldn't be
able to like
interact with anyone from the 1500s this
is a little disgusting but
okay my other fashion is history
so i was interested if in a thought
experiment which is like imagine if like
william shakespeare appeared in wherever
you're sitting with your computer or
your phone
like imagine if like someone from the
1500s appeared
would you be able to communicate with
with him like would you be able to
communicate with the author of this book
and explain to him that you're watching
a twitch stream where you're reading his
book
or would they just like faint but the
reality is
um oh my ipad died sorry i have to go to
my phone
but the reality is we probably wouldn't
be able to be in the same room as them
we would probably
faint because oh i got a donation one
sec
sorry okay okay that wasn't it so
basically
they smelled so bad because they
showered like once a year and their
teeth were in such
that we wouldn't be able to like be in
the same room as them and i read this by
a historian
uh like they and they like change their
underwear like two times a year or
something uh
and like that was like actually a thing
so anyways
they would burn you at the stake no like
i think you would understand
um well like the the privileged
you know people in the society
the elite they watch like once a year
once a week
okay so let's see if i can translate
some of the 15 this is 1561
1561 ry lopez himself wrote this book
this is ry lopez um
this is ray lopez chapter
whatever this is seven in which are
declared
the names of the chess
and how are names of the tribe is a
chess piece i actually know this word
chess is defined by the
table with like eight lines
okay this is actually easier for me to
read than the russian
okay i don't care 10th chapter
the form of the king
let's see if we can find any moves
bishops i think our feel is the bishop
knights here he talks about
rooks roque could be castle or rook
pawns
let me see i don't know if this is
interesting but i think it is
oh he's talking about the old form of
the pawns isn't this guy realize he's
old
he's talking about in which is talked
about the old form
of the pawn which used to be such which
is situated in front of the
queen's file
the pawn which is situated in front of
the i'm not sure what our the the
queen's
file
has some form
a man with the right arm and he's
talking about bread
and wine when did he go from the deep on
to bread and wine man did these guys in
the 15 i just think about anything about
except their next glass of wine where
does he actually define the rylopa as i
wonder
huh i don't see any moves though
yeah he's not actually giving any moves
he's just talking and talking and
talking
i mean i see the chess pieces here but
he's just talking
there's no diagrams
he's talking about beauty
yeah nowhere back at the beginning so
these were old books where like they
didn't really talk about
i guess he's defining stuff but he's not
really
oh yes openings yes the other
way of starting the game with the king
spawn
one second
yes wow notation i found notation this
is really cool
this is notation okay so
the other way to start the game and he
says
queen spawn four squares one sec
queen spawn four squares same with
black i think lomesmo is the same so e4
e5
alfield so e4
oh bishop c4
i'll feel this right okay one second
e4 e5
i'm just reading yeah he's analyzing
if if black retreats his bishop
huh
okay let's read this uh it's phil is
king's bishop yes
yes yes that's what i thought okay
e4 e5
of so kings bishop to c4
and but like he's talking about the
queen's bishop but the queen's bishop
cannot move
like because white has played e4
oh c4 oh c3 oh
so this is like e4 e5 bishop c4 bishop
c5 c3
knight f6
yeah so he's analyzing basically this is
really cool
um yeah so this guy in the 1500s is
casually analyzing
chess games you might conjure up demons
but these are chess these are friendly
demons these are chess demons
all right but i gotta end oh 25 49
viewers look at this
i mean isn't that cool we found ry
lopez's book
on chess and this guy just like casually
500 years ago sitting over a chess book
and uh and making moves i i don't know
if that's not cool then
what is in short that's why i think
history is cool
um but basically there's many
books written in the 1600s we can look
at philidor's book
from the 1700s but that's in french
and i'm sure it's been translated
there's probably even an early
translation
and that's the power of the internet you
can just look at that book fully
digitized from some library
where it was filmed uh yeah i mean we're
reading it 500 years later but we're
imagining this guy just sitting
around analyzing that's another reason
the chess
an underestimated reason chess is
beautiful is because
uh it unites people of all ages and like
what other activity
other than like eating and
drinking have people been doing well
i feel like there's a lot of fossil
answers to this but
in a non-vulgar sense uh like what other
answered well what other entertainment
activities have people been doing for
500 years
plenty but you know what i mean um
that is another question by the way to
which i
dedicated some historical
research but i will eventually do a
mature only stream where i talk about
that
uh so anyways i'm sure it's a question a
lot of people are curious about but i
will not talk about it right now
um but anyways trust me i've researched
i've researched a lot of different
things um
i'll explain what i mean later
but we need to round off with one last
game
before i go to sleep before i go to
sleep
we will play one more speedrun game
and then sorry i did not mean to do this
apparently there's a name in this stuff
and then we will end
now i do have to sleep because i have
commentary starting
in nine hours okay i have not watched
money heist
you guys ready for one last game
all right after consulting the ancient
texts
i'm ready to destroy a 1600 this time
who plays the scandinavian
okay now in the scandinavian we know
already that knight c3 is
the best move to attack the queen and
develop a knight
now we occupy the center with d4
and now we follow the ancient wisdom
of petrov who said to develop the knight
uh
to f3 first i don't think we played this
guy actually
i disagree now he's just moving his
pawns
and there is no particular way in which
we should respond
no no we did not play this guy the last
time uh there is no particular way that
we should respond to this other than to
continue development uh
are you sure we played him well i'm
looking at my game history i don't see
him but anyways
bishop d3 is simple
oh it's just the overlay hasn't changed
there we go
the over that's so weird it contained
the name of the last opponent but the
the moves are transmitted
transmitting correctly okay so
let's centralize the knight that was
really funny
and develop our bishop so right now i'm
just developing all my pieces i'm not
doing anything crazy
which is why i'm moving fast
okay now what should we do in this
yeah i was like what what should we do
in this position let's bring our queen
out to f3 which is a very typical way to
apply pressure on his position
notice that i'm also giving up the d4
pawn and
there is a reason that i'm doing that
and the reason that i'm doing that is
because he's so
poorly developed if he takes on d4 with
his queen his queen is going to be
incredibly vulnerable to attack
now what should we do in this position
we can win a pawn
it's the right lopez demon that's right
lopez
loose pieces drop off
boom if he takes we take the bishop
whose pieces drop off that's a free pawn
there's no reason not to take it
okay he goes knight d5 so he attacks the
bishop let's take it
now we do need to move the knight away
so let's move it back to c3
okay so we're up upon we're in good
shape he's probably gonna go here
nope he's gonna go f6 okay now what
should we do in this
situation and i'll give you guys a hint
we can create a counter threat against
his pawn on h7 because we have a bishop
on t3 that's very very strong
a lot of people might think the move is
queen h5 but be very very careful
because if we oh we got another oh my
goodness
oh my lance
got another one from gem jam another 10
000 are you
kidding me i will have a good night
we're gonna go queen h3
so that g6 doesn't come with tempo
what a day this has been and culminating
in
two bombs dropped by jen jim now we're
going to move our night away now that
we've provoked the weaknesses in his
king side
and king h8 pin what does this tell us
about what we should do thank you so
much
what should we do here
boom if he will take his opponent on g6
yes
and the game is almost over that is the
second and again
we do the same thing we did earlier we
just take a pawn and we drop the bishop
back
okay now we have a really nice tactic
how do i see this tactic what i'm seeing
is that the queen defends the pawn on h7
against checkmate
we know that when the queen defends a
pawn that's not a good situation we can
take a third pun
and if he takes the queen oh sorry if he
takes the knight we can take on h7
and the game will be boy and lodge the
game will be over
now he's going to go knight 97 now most
people here would take the rook
the the thing about this is we can do a
lot more than take the rook we can do a
lot better because we have this h file
open we can attack
down that h file following the ancient
wisdom of the greats with knight takes
h7 we don't need to take bishop takes h7
because
if bishop h7 would give up the knight
and that same knight can be used to go
to h7
himself and
this is just going to be
completely winning we are up four pawns
and we are crushing him with an attack
okay now let's find the checkmate
he has also given up his rook but there
is mate in two moves
how do we find the checkmate we realize
that we can move the night away with a
discover check
our second mission in this position is
to cover the g8 square because after we
move the knight that is going to be his
only escape square
for the king and that's how you often
when you're discovering a check and you
want to checkmate your opponent's king
the way that you want to think about the
discoveries can i move my piece away
such that that very same piece somehow
contributes the mating mechanism
as you guys can see the move is knight
f6 check
the game is over it's mate very simple
game we just developed our pieces
and this is why i don't recommend
opening such as the scandi
to a lot of players in the intermediate
range because
they tend to do stuff like this giving
us a huge lead in development
the one thing i'd like to talk about is
what would have happened if we had if he
had gone queen takes d4
now when you look at this move the
immediate thing you should notice
is the relationship between the queens
so if this bishop could move away with
check then that would win the queen so
you need to find a tactic in order to
force the king onto a square
where you could deliver check to this
looks like a complicated combination but
the logic behind it no pun intended is
very simple you're just trying to get
the king onto a square
or you can deliver the discovery check
so he couldn't do this
and that meant he had to allow us to
continue putting our pieces on very good
squares
now we play knight takes b5 using the
fact that the bishop is unprotected
we drop the knight back we attack h7 if
he had taken the knight
we take it check and checkmate is very
simple we can even checkmate with a pawn
do you take c5 and
after knight g4 i mean his position has
already been softened up
we take on g6 we take on f6 distracting
the queen notice how our own queen and
i've mentioned this often the queen is
often sort of the supporting actress
a queen defends on g2 and simultaneously
is responsible for uh
basically he's the agent of of checkmate
what if he took the pawn later that's a
good question so if he took the pawn
here
we would have just defended the knight
and then brought the other look how
amazing white's position is
uh even up on down so basically this is
just completely overwhelming because
white's got pieces on amazing squares
and you can slide the queen over to h3
and create threats against the h7 pawn
so if he goes h6 you can already give a
discovery and win the queen
uh what if yeah so there's there's a
bunch of tactical details here but the
long and the short of it is that
white's got a huge attack and the rest
was
very straightforward now just moving
knight back to f6
and covering g8 we could have also taken
the rook of course with total
devastation but
we decided to play a little bit more
precisely
okay that concludes today's streaming
guys
i'm exhausted uh i will go to sleep and
i have commentary at 9 am tomorrow
this has been a day of
a legendary day uh we have
three i can't understand how many
viewers we have 3 000 viewers and maybe
i should continue then
maybe i should just play blitz or
something but at the same time i need to
make the responsible decision and go to
sleep
so i will be commentating
brandon wants me to play blitz oh
i guess some people want me to say
curious chimpanzee just gifted five subs
the party continues curious chimpanzee
thank you for the five gifted
to bad wolf our fennel ducati
fellow bailey and johnny double zero
but i think the thrust of it is that
people want me
to sleep but anyways
just a couple of things before i do
uh basically we had of course the
earliest stream when
people gifted incredible amount of subs
and the outpouring of support today is
also very much
welcome oh my god and this never ends
this day just never ends we're almost at
31 70. yazizy commands me to go to sleep
and i will
for five gifted yes easy thanks again
we got so much done today we had logic
in the stream gifting 150 subs
we had blitz we had speed running we had
chess history and i wanted to deliver a
good stream to end
the night because that is the least that
i can do given the support today
and uh i will get some rest i will be
back tomorrow morning for the
speed chess championship for robert hess
in the like the rapper
yeah this was a great stream i think we
went down chess history there's a lot
more to talk about
i will prepare some more materials for
more history streams
uh but in the meantime i gotta go
replenish myself get some rest
maybe watch half an episode of i gotta
choose a show
if only there was an american horror
story season i hadn't seen
but anyways um
what's a what's a good youtube channel
on history tonight okay i'll do some
exploring
so versus due to tomorrow you don't want
to miss it 9 00 a.m pacific
12 eastern with my partner in crime
robert hess
tomorrow i have a very very busy day
after that i have my scan for my surgery
so
i can't promise that i'll be streaming
tomorrow but i'll try to get a quick
stream in during the day
and we will do more blitz and chess
history
alright guys a huge huge shout out to
this amazing
community you guys have are responsible
for everything that happens i
do my very small part to put in my
effort but
this is all thanks to thanks to the
generosity of everybody here so
i'm honored to have these kinds of
people watching my streams thank you to
all of you
stay safe folks have
an amazing night or morning wherever you
are
and all right and i will raid
let's see who i will raid i will raid
uh chess bro let's just rate chess bra
or voy boy
well let's just write chess bro
all right my boys eric amman
you will be in their capable hands stay
safe everybody
huge shout out to everybody who supports
and watches
goodnight folks i'll see you tomorrow
bye everybody
[Music]